I got a call from a brand new dad this morning.
Take a listen to this voicemail left to me
at two one nine two.
David P..
Hey, David long-Time, listener, First-Time
Caller here from Seattle.
Yes.
Well, listen in on my daughter.
My first daughter was born in.
About 20 minutes ago, one of my first stops
is Wow.
Oh, my gosh.
I just brought a child into this world during
this election and during everything that's
going on.
I just love for you to give a shout out on
your show to my daughter, Nicoya, just reassuring
you that I'm going to be able to raise my
daughter as well.
All right.
Thank you.
You do a great job, and I really appreciate
your work.
Well, listen, congratulations.
Welcome to the world, to Nicoya.
I think we have to be realistic here.
You're weak.
We don't have control.
Much like I said to the caller yesterday.
The philosophy of stoicism comes to mind.
Clearly, what matters is whether this new
dad does everything he can to improve the
world for his daughter.
Ultimately, it is not up to him.
A planet of seven eight billion people is
not one that can be controlled by just one
person.
But the fact that you're thinking in these
terms tells me that you're going to do a great
job and we all have to work together in order
to create the best possible situation, not
just for our kids, but their kids and their
kids and their kids.
And we do have a monumental event that could
alter the course of history.
Coming up just a few weeks from now on the
bonus show today, a Saudi court has sentenced
suspects in this Jamal Khashoggi murder.
We will talk about a Corona virus guideline
avoiding bar, which secretly had 300 people
inside of it.
And we will also talk about the continuation
of Julian Assange, his extradition hearing.
This story is still going on and it's unlikely
to go away anytime soon.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Remember, this program is mostly funded by
members.
I am asking you for your support, if you like
what we do or even if you hate it, but think
it's important.
Grab yourself a membership.
Join Patman dot com and you'll be able to
join us on the bonus show as well.